welcome sir my brother how's everything
going man you got a lot more jewelry on
I mean
what's this watch here
it's funny I knew when I walked in here
you were going to make a comment about
my jacket but I took off now and we had
a pretty ridiculous Gucci jacket on that
was very nice yeah I know it's just you
know it was a big puffer jacket it's
cold outside and I was wearing this
short sleeve and I was either gonna wear
that or like a mediocre looking one no
you're like this you got your Messiah on
though yes you're excited for the World
Cup is this like a time of year or time
of every four years you're excited for
yes this is really the only real thing
that I super follow in sports right like
I'm a basketball fan but I can't say I'm
like really following it the way I used
to right after Kobe and everything I
mean you have a King James song though
yeah I love LeBron but of course you
know and I follow it but you know but
soccer is different I was gonna say
because you are Armenian but you grew up
in the Netherlands right yeah I'm not
Argentinian you're not Argentinian but
you like Messi Messi this is just like a
symbol of greatness you know what I mean
it's like a Jordan jersey a Kobe jersey
right you know what I'm saying
um but yeah I grew up in I'm Armenian
but we don't have
I mean we have a team but not in a World
Cup right
um unfortunately maybe one day
um but I grew up in the Netherlands
Amsterdam so and growing up in Europe
like as far as soccer that's like
deep rooted culture you know what I mean
it's different like people here don't
really understand it yet right no for
sure for sure it's definitely like when
when the country's playing there's
nobody outside you know everyone's like
watching it everyone I'm talking about
my mom right now is watching the
Netherlands play like you know what I
mean you guys beat the US yes we did I'm
sorry were you excited about that yeah I
expected it you know you guys wasn't
ready yet even though the Netherlands
this year we're not as good as we once
where usually are you know we known as
the greatest nation to never win the
World Cup that's interesting a couple
times finals always in the semis
quarters but never actually won